各位投资朋友你们好
我是你们的分析师Gary
今天要来跟大家介绍ACY证券所独家推出的指标
唐奇安通道
接下来会先透过实际操作跟各位说明如何使用这个指标
那么为什么我们要使用这个指标
以及各位投资朋友能从中获得什么样的效益
最后再为各位解释这个指标
如何去做安装
好的
首先开启您的MT4平台
接下来来到左边的导航窗口
找到刚刚您所下载的唐旗安通道指标
接着把它拖放到图形上
这边会有一个输入参数
可以让各位去做一个选择
如果您需要的话
可以在这边进行调整
也就是说可以选择不同的参数
那这个参数呢
它主要就是画过去几根K线的一个高低点
如果说我们是用在日图上面
用20的话就代表
它这个通道画出来的是过去20天的一个高低点
那如果是用在一小时图呢
20就代表它会画出过去20小时的最高价和最低价
所组成的通道
好
那这边的话我们就先不用去动参数
如果你有需要你再去做调整
接下来按下确定就可以了
那老师这边已经有先载入指标了
好如果你按下去确定之后
就会出现了像这样的一个图形
那这边蓝色的这个线是唐琴安通道的上轨
红色的线的话就是唐琴安通道的一个下轨那这个下轨本身就代表过去20个小时当中的一个最低价蓝色的这个线就是过去20个小时一个最高价所组成的一条线
那么为什么我们要使用唐齐安通道这个指标呢
其实距今过去30多年前交易界有一个有名的实验
实验的内容是想证实
伟大的交易员是与生俱来的
还是说可以经由后天训练得逞
当时他们所使用的交易系统
就是所谓的通道突破系统
后来的实验结果证实
其实只要有纪律的遵守
长期有利可图的交易规则
就算你不是天生对于数字敏感的投资者
一样能在市场大有窄货
而当时他们所使用的通道就是唐奇安通道
因此这个独家指标是经典通道突破体系当中的重要组成因子
由于唐奇安通道是过去K棒的高低点所组成的
假设参数选择20作用在日图上
那么画出来的通道的上下轨
就是代表过去20天K线的最高点和最低点
而最高点和最低点本身
其实就是市场行情的极值所在
所以也可以把这个指标的上轨
当成是未来行情的潜在阻力
而下轨当成是未来行情的潜在支撑
有了这个指标之后
各位其实可以透过图形的视觉化
来得知过去任意跟K线的高低点
所组成的通道
那这本身就是一个所谓的动态支撑与阻力同时各位也能借由这个指标去搭配各个交易品种的属性
去开发顺势或者是逆势的交易策略
比如说以这张图为例
这是傍澳货币队的日线走势图
傍澳货币队它本身的一个商品特质
是属于比较有趋势性的商品
所以您可以看得到
它在8月下旬的时候
开始跌破了过去20天K线的低点
代表说目前市场已经开始趋于弱势
一直到最近的11月
价格还是是处于下跌的情况
因此空单如果在8月下旬的时候进场
将会非常有利可图
那么唐奇安通道这个指标
它其实适用于所有商品
不管是外汇、股指、贵金属
以及加密货币的部分
其实都能够做运用
那因为刚刚我们有提到
这个指标可以用在顺势的交易
也就是说突破上轨考虑做多
突破下轨考虑做空
那接下来我们来看看
用在逆势交易的方向效果如何
也就是突破上轨的时候
我们考虑做空
突破下跪的时候
我们考虑做多
那这个图形呢
它是这个澳洲股指的
一个小时走势图
那由于这个澳洲股指
它本身的一个商品属性
是属于比较盘整类型的
所以我们在价格跌破下跪的时候
会考虑做多
各位可能看到这边
在8月24号的时候
曾经一度跌破下跪
那么后续市场价格有做一个反弹结果又来到了上轨那这边如果按照我们刚刚讲的一个逆势交易的方式的话这边会做一个买进然后这边突破上轨的时候呢
会做一个卖出的一个动作
那这边卖出之后呢
这边又会再买进
这边买进之后又会在这边做一个卖出
各位可以看到这笔可能会有一点点损失
那这边的卖出的话
这边他又会买进
所以这笔会赚钱
然后这边又在买进
买进之后来到上轨
这边又卖出
所以各位可以看到
这个逆势的一个策略
透过唐奇安通道来实现的话
其实效果是很不错的
那各位如果对于刚刚
老师提到这个
市场本身的商品属性要如何判断的话
其实可以来听
Gary老师在ACY证券的一个讲座
为了有些对于MT4这个平台
还不是很熟悉的投资朋友
这边会分几个步骤
告诉各位要如何安装指标
首先打开您的MT4终端
接着开启左上角菜单的文件
并且选择打开数据文件夹
数据文件夹打开之后
点选MQL4文件夹
接着再点选Indicates文件夹
然后把您所下载的指标
也就是唐奇安通道
放在这个Indicators文件夹之下
放好之后
把MT4终端关闭
接着重新打开MT4终端
这样指标就会显示在您的MT4里面了
以上就是针对唐锡安通道
这个指标的说明以及应用
预祝各位投资朋友
在未来使用这个指标之后
能让交易更加顺手
我们下次再见
优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive